c'est jour férié et fête nationale en
russe dans le petit village de pioche à
600 km de la capitale
c'est moscovite profite des dernières
heures du long week-end sur les rives de
la volga
l'auberge qu'il n' a retapé et qu'elle
gère aujourd'hui avec son fils daniel et
un petit trésor en soi
leur philosophie renouer avec le
patrimoine russe longtemps boudée au
profit de la culture occidentale
même avant la sanction une démission de
visite privée de chastelain et ziti si
c'était de montrer aux gens pas
seulement aux étrangers mais plus aux
moscovites que le récit c'est beaucoup
plus que moscou est de montrer la
culture est étrangement de faire notre
mission encore plus spécial car demander
à n'importe quel client dans la pièce
est trop russe et voyager vers l'ouest
aujourd'hui c'est plus compliqué que
jamais faute de visa le tourisme local
est devenu une alternative avantageuse
pour la classe moyenne dit ousmane qui
atteint depuis plus d'un an
visa pour aller aux états unis photo
pascal arrache frost mountainview ça
nous permet de leur ouvrir les yeux de
leur montrer que la culture russe ce
n'est pas quelque chose de très pauvres
nous avons ouvert un atelier de bois oui
car tout ça c'est nouveau que s'attendre
à nouveau et c'est justement pour
pallier à la chute du rouble et à la
pénurie de produits étrangers sénat a
décidé de cultiver sur place et de se
perfectionner localement il ya des
choses que les sanctions vous ont obligé
afin d'installer scott morrison je tombe
et à un mémo on a réfléchi on s'est posé
la question dit elle qu'est ce que nous
savons faire de nombreux à lui failli
agressive et plus on s'est rappelé que
faisaient nos grands parents des jouets
de l'art des meubles et regardez autour
de vous scruff mais la réalité c'est que
la russie s'est plutôt bien ajusté et le
baume dans l'industrie agroalimentaire
en est l'exemple le plus éloquent quand
anna s'est installé à mattox à la
campagne près de saint-pétersbourg il ya
cinq ans elle n'avait que deux petites
chèvres sans france des réseaux
présentent
puis les sanctions sont arrivés
l'embargo sur tous les produits
européens a été une véritable
bénédiction et a commencé à nous
soutenir financièrement dit elle à mon
avis il est même que trop les résultats
5 1 et 6 1 animaux de ferme plus tard en
entreprise 20 son fromage et même de la
viande de qualité aux quatre coins du
pays
c'est une stratégie très gagnante sur la
longue durée aujourd'hui sont devenus
seule suffisante en cochon et en
volailles sentiment incroyable
l'économiste alexandre step hanescu et
chefs d'entreprise à moscou il a été aux
premières loges de ce nouveau
protectionnisme russe je veux dire moi
j'ai recruté nous avons recruté pour des
clients russes des spécialistes
étrangers qu'ils font des productions
fromage et donc tous ces secteurs là les
entreprises étrangères ces sanctions
sont levés n'y reviendront plus jamais
ils sont perdus pour tout jour perdu est
remplacé par des producteurs comme anna
qui embauche aujourd'hui 30 personnes et
compte parmi ses clients réguliers des
grandes chaînes de restaurants
[Musique]
parmi les restaurants qui ne peuvent
plus se passer de ces produits locaux le
bloc de saint pétersbourg pourtant son
jeune chef evgueni comme beaucoup
d'autres a cru et les sanctions allez
achever la restauration
[Musique]
nous avions la fenêtre grande ouverte
sur l'europe
et quand elle s'est fermé on a dû se
débrouiller aujourd'hui tout le concept
du restaurant repose sur le made in
rachat tartare de boeuf de la région de
voronej pétoncles de murmansk oursins de
l'extrême orient
les sanctions hors finalement à jouer en
faveur de l'industrie culinaire expliqué
gainey car nous assistons à la naissance
d'une gastronomie voulait il faut bien
comprendre que sanctionner un état
ça unifie la population les sanctions
peuvent monter si motivé toute une
génération dépendante des marques
étrangères à se prendre en main et cela
ne fait que commencer
[Musique]
l'idée c'était on va faire des sanctions
les russes vont souffrir on descend dans
la rue se redresser contre leur pouvoir
c'est caramba encore raté
ça marche pas c'est parce qu'il passe en
russie
et si la prochaine vague de mesures
devaient être encore plus dur
l'économie russe est mieux préparé que
jamais adopte la russie s'adaptera
toujours dit l'islam 90 feuilleton
[Musique]
l'histoire l'a prouvé et le prouve
encore une fois
[Musique]